show this show now anything you want to
say to set up in case anyone out there
doesn't know this story
yeah Deadpool is a mercenary who has
who's giving who basically comes down
with cancer he's forced to his last
resort is to enter this program which
hideously scars his entire body head to
toe but also gives him the healing
factors that Wolverine has so and he's
called the Merc with the mouth he's a
guy that just cannot shut up which I'm
feeling vaguely reminiscent to at this
moment yeah let's take a look at this
incredible trailer for Deadpool go I
[Applause]
love you way too awesome we can flame
this you're right cancer is only my
liver lungs prostate and brain all
things I can live without
what if I told you we can make you
better
you're a fighter we can give you
abilities most men only dream of make
you a superhero
you just promise you'll do right by me
so I can do right by someone else and
please don't make the supersuit green or
animated one thing that never survives
this place it's a sense of humor we'll
see about that posh spicy oh come on you
know leave me all alone here with less
angry Rosie O'Donnell
[Music]
wait you may be wondering why the red
suit well that's so bad guys can't see
me bleed this guy's got the right idea
he wore the brown pants daddy needs to
express some rage
how many gets a break
it reeks like old lady pants in here
sounds like you have a dick in your
mouth I think you are hard to look at
like a testicle with teeth
you look like Freddy Krueger face the
topographical map of Utah
stay out
oh I'm touching myself tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
honk look like an avocado had sex with
an older avocado thank you
[Applause]
TJ Miller by the way the best so happy
to see TJ Miller in there we're huge
fans of his ne and you guys have such a
great thing they're so much fun with him
cannot keep a straight face around that
guy's hysterical yeah well thank you so
much a for for being here for premiering
this incredible trailer we're all
looking forward to the film and
congratulations again on your baby
that's so thank you very much invaders
2016
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please